sechs eurofighter die sollten innerhalb
eines tages also 24 stunden in singapur
sein eigentlich das war die channel
challenge aber beim start da war noch
alles okay und danach sind fünf
abgehoben zunächst richtung abu dhabi
und einer im nicht ja in abu dhabi
sozusagen gestrandet und zwar
ausgerechnet der vorzeige jets dort der
luftwaffe genau der den man extra bemalt
hatte für dieses training mit den farben
den flaggen der teilnehmenden länder der
vorzeige jet also technische panne
hydraulikprobleme bei diesem jet air
also nicht pünktlich in singapur ankam
alle fünf anderen jets kam pünktlich an
für die geht sogar noch mal weiter nach
australien zur großen übung dort wir
sprechen jetzt mit generalleutnant ingo
gerhartz hierbei bild live danke dass
sie uns zur verfügung stehen und einmal
aufklären können was steckt da drin wo
steckt der teufel im detail bei dem
vorzeichen der luftwaffe
also zunächst mal wir sind da in
24 stunden hier in asien und das zum
ersten mal seit bestehen der luftwaffe
dass wir mit dieser anzahl an flugzeugen
in asien sind und es ist ja nicht nur
der eurofighter als kampfflugzeug
sondern auf der a 3 30 als tanker drei
tagen wird verlegt und insgesamt vier
auf hinter dem transporter und ja wir
mussten ein flugzeug zurück lassen das
nehmen wir sehr gelassen ein
hochkomplexes kampfflugzeug da ist ein
ein technischer defekt ebenso einer
verlegung nicht auszuschließen wir
hatten probleme mit der hydraulik und
über diese entfernung geht man da auf
jeden fall auf nummer sicher und
deswegen wäre sind gerade dabei die
maschine zu reparieren und bevor wir
haben sie ja gerade wenn die hypo in
australien beginnt wird werden wir sechs
eure feinde in australien haben sagt der
größte respekt dafür für die leistung
der piloten sowieso für ihre leistung
beim reparieren jetzt auch trotzdem war
das ja eine challenge man hat versucht
alle sechs eben in dieser zeit zu
bringen würden sie jetzt sagen challenge
verloren
ich würde sagen ich alles gewonnen
werden auch von beginn an sagen können
dass wir vier eurofighter hier ihn
verlegen und 20 das haben zb die
engländer gemacht aber wir haben eben
die ja ich würde sagen die leute
vielleicht etwas höher gelegt so jetzt
sind es sechs geworden sondern fünf aber
das wichtigste ist natürlich dass wir in
24 stunden hier waren das wollten wir
demonstrieren dass man über diese
strecke eben mit einer luftwaffe so
schnell sein kann wir können sich
vorstellen was das ist natürlich für
mensch und material bedeutet hat also
unsere piloten sind hier gerade sehr
erschöpft aus dem maschinen gestiegen
und wie gesagt das wichtigste ist jetzt
für uns das nächste ziel übungsbeginn
der ist nächsten montag und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher wir werden mit sechs
maschinen mit sechs eurofighter die
übungen in australien beginnen danke
ihnen noch mal so wie gesagt großer
respekt sie sagen völlig erschöpft
ausgestiegen das glaube ich sofort ich
würde da keine minuten aushalten in so
einem eurofighter aber noch einmal mit
meinem laienhaften verständnis das muss
doch was ganz besonderes auch sein für
ihre piloten die sonst über deutschland
fliegen oder natürlich über das nato
gebiet hier und jetzt können sie bis
nach singapur sogar noch weiter nach
australien lassen jetzt einmal in das
piloten herz schauen
absolut das ist fern piloten ist das
natürlich ein ganz tolles erlebnis
man kann sagen ein traum erfüllt sich
für die piloten in diesem in diesem
gebiet in asien fliegen zu dürfen sie
wissen dass wir gerade auf das nehmen
wir natürlich auch sehr ernst parallel
wieder den luftraum sich dann an der
nato ostflanke aber sie können sich
vorstellen als wir gefragt haben wer
möchte nach asien verlegen sind alle
hände hoch gegangen und einige piloten
die durften ist jetzt machen und ich
habe gerade mit den ersten piloten
gesprochen der erste sagte mir gleich
für mich hat sich ein lebenstraum
erfüllt hier in dieser region jetzt
fliegen zu dürfen also das ist für einen
piloten herz schon wirklich das größte
ja das glaube ich danke für die
schilderung danke für den blick in ihre
piloten herz alles gute für das weitere
training und ja für die technik auch
dann auf dem weiteren weg danke ihnen
[Musik]